et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Nicolas Dupont-Aignan bonjour bonjour
madame
président de deux boules à France en
étant ça pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Fabrice wesser
Redon du groupe hébral les journaux
régionaux de l'Est de la France bonjour
Fabrice bonjour Nicolas Dupont
des retraites Nicolas Dupont-Aignan
puisqu'une manifestation est prévenue et
prévue jeudi prochain mobilisation
syndicale et grève est-ce que vous irez
manifester aux côtés des syndicats jeudi
l'homme politique n'a pas venu j'allais
dire compliqué la vie des syndicats mais
peut-être que personnellement comme
citoyen je descendrai dans la rue
pourquoi vous faites la différence entre
je crois que les syndicats sont très
soucieux et c'est normal de pas avoir de
récupération politique d'où que ce soit
en revanche moi si vous me posez la
question en titre personnel j'invite les
Français à descendre massivement dans la
rue est-ce que car je pense que le
gouvernement ne respectera que la force
Pacifique bien sûr dans le calme
sereinement il s'agit surtout pas de de
violence ni de d'excès mais face à un
pouvoir complètement inconscient qui se
trompe gravement je pense que seul une
très large mobilisation des Français
peut le faire reculer et c'est important
parce qu'on peut pas continuer comme ça
à mépriser les Français à descendre dans
la rue vous appelez à plus est-ce que
vous appelez à des blocages est-ce que
vous appelez une France à l'arrêter je
suis un homme respectueux des
institutions je veux pas compliquer la
vie des Français je dis qu'il serait
important que les Français se fassent
entendre et je leur dis toujours la même
chose si vous êtes résigné
si vous ne bougez jamais si vous ne
faites rien et bien ce pouvoir et cet
homme vont vous tondre vont vous piller
et ça ne s'arrêtera jamais vous avez
commis l'erreur de le réélire
rattrapez-vous en bloquant c'est-à-dire
en manifestant sereinement il y a une
journée de manifestation et c'est pas
c'est très important pour la suite parce
que je le dis comme je le pense cette
réforme est abominable elle est inutile
et injuste on a bien compris elle ne
sert à rien soutenez cette mobilisation
Nicolas Dupont-Aignan je la soutiens
totalement
y compris pour les régimes spéciaux non
sur les régimes spéciaux c'est différent
mais cette réforme ne touche pas au
régime spéciaux cette réforme d'abord
faut reprendre les choses au début elle
est inutile le financement des retraites
est assuré on nous raconte n'importe
quoi elle est prématurée de toute façon
il y a un excédent cette année de 3
milliards qui était pas prévu le déficit
pour les années suivantes on répète ça
tout le monde répète mais les chiffres
du corps je les ai lu lisez-les vous
verrez hypothétiquement en 2030 7,5
milliards de déficits sur 350 et ce sera
plus à l'époque c'est-à-dire l'épaisseur
d'un trait et au même moment on a 20
milliards d'euros gaspillés dans des
millions de fausses cartes vitales on
donne toujours plus de milliards à
l'Union européenne il y a des des
gaspillages insensés qu'on ne traite pas
et on nous dit le régime des retraites
est en danger dans 10 ans peut-être
qu'il y aura un léger déficit on en sait
absolument rien et sans parler des
réserves qui ont été faites dont on ne
parle jamais il y a pas de problème de
déficit aujourd'hui
il y a pas de déficit aujourd'hui il y a
un excédent il y a une réforme Touraine
qui a déjà été très dure qui est très
difficile à digérer pour nos concitoyens
elle était ou pas la réforme tourelle la
réforme Touraine pouvait être nécessaire
mais là trop c'est
pas toucher ça pour vous pas tout de
suite on est à 42 il faut attendre de
voir moi je suis on est à 62 ans 42 ans
d'annuité point trop n'en faut et je
vous dis que c'est absurde la réforme
Touraine ou garder le rythme de la
région
je refuse non plus ah écoutez il y a une
accélération et un passage à 64 ans donc
d'une part il y a aucun besoin de
surcroît je vais vous dire ce que je
pense c'est que nous avons un pays qui a
des défis colossaux on sort exténué de
la crise du covid on a une hausse des
prix colossale on a un recul du pouvoir
d'achat on a des défis de relocalisation
industrielle fondamentaux et on va
mettre la France par dessus tête pour
rien dans une espèce de crise nerveuse
tout ça parce qu'il y a un gouvernement
qui fait de l'agitation de de l'angoisse
existentielle notre pays a besoin de
confiance
et je vais vous dire ce qui est pire
donc d'abord c'est inutile donc il y a
qu'on se pose la question 2024 2027 on
verra où on en est mais là aujourd'hui
c'est inutile deuxième point non mais à
quoi ça sert de créer de l'angoisse chez
nos concitoyens de créer une crise
sociale après une crise covid après une
crise de pouvoir d'achat mais ce que la
France a besoin de ça c'est
irresponsable attitude du gouvernement
irresponsable le deuxième point sur
lequel je veux insister de cette réforme
c'est qu'elle est profondément injuste
d'ailleurs qui le disait qui le disait
c'est le président de la République en
2019 il l'a dit
reprenez l'extrait vidéo il le dit très
bien il dit c'est complètement aberrant
de faire peser sur les premiers de
cordées ceux qui ont été à nos côtés les
plus modestes parce que ceux qui ont
fait des études supérieures ça change
rien puisque vous savez que quand vous
avez commencé à 23 ans à travailler si
vous faites 42 ans vous prenez votre
retraite à
donc la réforme ne change rien pour les
classes supérieures mais en revanche
pour les ouvriers pour les premiers
cordées pour les gens en difficulté
alors là je peux vous dire c'est la
double peine c'est honteux cette réforme
elle est honteuse pour la pénibilité il
y a des mesures pour les parieurs
compensent en partie le drame de cette
réforme donc ne faisons pas la réforme
c'est créer une usine bureaucratique qui
n'a aucun sens
30% seulement des Français travaillent
entre 60 et 64 ans vous êtes jeté des
entreprises à 58 ans vous êtes usé par
le travail à 55 ans quand vous avez
commencé à 18 ans et on va vous dire ah
mais il faut continuer jusqu'à 64 ans
c'est le RSA qui va payer ce sont les
départements
quand même quel est fort
les licenciements continuent dans toutes
les entreprises ce sont des gens d'index
quel effort rien du tout restauration de
l'index pour vous c'est une c'est
n'importe quoi c'est un tableau de bord
ça change rien il faut des contraintes
est-ce que si est-ce que c'est dans
cette index il y a des contraintes pour
les entreprises et des sanctions c'est
ce que vous demandez attendez on a un
système à 62 ans pourquoi changer il y a
un excédent de 3 milliards pourquoi
faire peser sur les plus modestes une
réduction des pensions parce que ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est qu'à partir
du moment où vous prolongez jusqu'à 64
que l'ouvrier il est au chômage à partir
de 58 il y a encore 1600 emplois la
délocaliser il retrouve pas ils sont au
chômage à 58 il tirait jusqu'à 62 qu'à
un cas avec les dispositifs d'aide ils
vont être au RSA voilà la réalité ce
sont des coûts sociaux considérables
pour la société et c'est un signal
détestable qui est donné d'ailleurs il y
en a un qui le dit il y a de Mimos c'est
François Bayrou donc
se forme elle est insupportable et voilà
pourquoi je dis aux Français
il est moindre puisque il y a plusieurs
âge légal en fonction de votre début de
carrière sauf qu'à partir du moment où
vous mettez vous passez 62 à 64
d'ailleurs ils le font pour ça il fait
ils veulent faire des économies
ils vont les faire et ne rêvez pas cette
réforme est totalement antisociable moi
je suis un gaulliste social je suis pas
socialiste je suis pas mélenchonesque
mais je dis que
oser une réforme aussi injuste aussi
détestable sur les classes populaires
c'est vraiment insupportable et voilà
pourquoi moi je serai en pointe dans la
défense des droits des Français qui ont
travaillé dur d'ailleurs on parle tout
le temps de réhabilitation de la valeur
travail et on est en train de sacrifier
des gens qui ont travaillé
c'est incompréhensible est-ce que vous
pouvez approcher Emmanuel Macron
d'appliquer son programme cette réforme
il en a parlé pendant la campagne vous
reconnaissez que c'est pas une surprise
parce que moi je me souviens de la peine
majorité
et je me souviens de la campagne
législative très bien et le nombre de
gens qui me disaient à Monsieur
Dupont-Aignan on a voté Macron on a
peut-être fait une bêtise mais on a voté
Macron mais on va voter pour vous parce
que on va pas lui donner une majorité on
veut pas de la réforme de la retraite
donc si vous voulez quand Emmanuel
Macron nous dit j'ai été élu là-dessus
il se trompe il a été élu sur autre
chose sans doute je ne dis pas son
élection mais il a pas été élu sinon il
aurait eu une large majorité à
l'Assemblée si ça réforme était si
populaire d'ailleurs je remarque que une
très grande majorité des Français sont
très hostiles à cette réforme ce qu'il
voit bien qu'il y a un loup il voit bien
qu'il y a que c'est pas possible que
c'est à aucun sens alors prenons
quelques années et puis dans quelques
années voyons si le taux d'emploi des
seniors remonte dans notre société et
puis on verra d'ailleurs moi j'ai déposé
un proposition de référendum j'allais
vous demander et que les Français
arbitent c'est un choix majeur et ce
qu'on consacre un peu plus d'argent à la
retraite est-ce qu'on en consacre moins
c'est pourquoi majeur politique ça ne va
pas se faire au déboter comme ça vous
proposez donc une un référendum pour
cela il faut des signatures
j'y crois il faut des signatures de
députés de sénateurs
je crois d'après mon assistant d'un est
déjà une vingtaine je je saurai plus ce
soir
ça veut dire je suis en manque beaucoup
vous avez bon espoir de les obtenir ça
fait deux jours je la présente demain à
la presse moi je crois beaucoup parce
que les parlementaires vont être devant
leur responsabilité
d'abord ils vont voter mais pourquoi il
y aurait pas un grand débat et une vraie
on a un référendum d'initiative partagé
185 députés au sénateurs 4 millions un
peu plus de signatures mais moi je pense
qu'on peut les avoir quelle surprise ce
serait qui est un référendum obligé avec
êtes-vous pour le maintien 62 ans c'est
ma question vous imaginez qu'est-ce que
vous dites alors dans ce texte
aujourd'hui pourquoi le système des
retraites est pérenne contrairement à ce
qu'on dit
j'estime pourquoi cette réforme est
profondément injuste on pouvait être en
désaccord sur la réforme à points
quand il y a eu le grand sur la réforme
après on pouvait être en désaccord ou
pas mais elle avait une cohérence tandis
que là il y a aucune cohérence et donc
la question ce sera
je ne suis pas jusqu'au boutis je ne
suis pas d'accord avec Monsieur
Mélenchon quand il dit il faut revenir à
60 ans ça c'est pas possible
financièrement je pense que notre pays a
besoin de calme a besoin d'optimisme a
besoin de confiance ces penche tant de
l'huile sur le feu à tout moment alors
qu'il y a aucun problème immédiat
vraiment je ne comprends pas alors on a
bien compris que vous appelez les
Français à descendre dans la rue je dis
comment pas si l'allemand comment au
Parlement puisque vous êtes député vous
comptez vous y opposer
mes modestes moyens avec mes arguments
et en appelant les parlementaires
justement à demander un référendum
d'initiative populaire partagé vous
pensez qu'il y aura un vrai débat parce
qu'on entend la patronne des Verts qui
dit qu'il va qu'elle veut transformer
l'Assemblée nationale en zate même si
elle est pas députée la France insoumise
qui veut déposer 1000 amendements par
député ça fera 75000 amendements est-ce
que ce sont des bonnes les bonnes
méthodes pour vous moi je pense que le
Parlement doit être toujours sérieux et
donner une image de crédibilité ce qui a
pas toujours le cas malheureusement
l'assemblée et je pense
parfois si la branche sur laquelle ils
sont assis donc je suis en désaccord
avec leur mode de fonctionnement je
regrette voilà maintenant je vais vous
dire la question ça va pas se faire au
Parlement puisque d'après ce que j'ai vu
les républicains sont complices de cette
réforme donc la question elle est
magique ben oui vous la reconnaissez pas
de la cohérence de voter une réforme qui
tourne depuis des années mais la
cohérence
oui ils sont cohérents avec leur chimère
et leur erreur maintenant de fait il y a
une nouvelle majorité qui est en train
de se mettre en place il faut le
reconnaître voilà c'est ils ont le droit
ils ont le droit de préférer Macron aux
autres mais les français Emmanuel Macron
présente une réforme qu'il propose
depuis des années non mais attendez les
Français seront juges moi j'ai encore eu
hier une galette de Debout la France où
il y avait plein de républicains
d'adhérents républicains qui ont déchiré
leurs cartes parce que voir Monsieur nos
amis que j'aime bien d'ailleurs
messieurs cioti Retailleau marlex qui
sont des personnes estimables à la
servir la soupe à Madame borne la sortie
de Matignon c'était une image c'est un
suicide pour eux qui se suicident c'est
sur leurs droits mais c'est ça pour vous
c'est un suicide oui ils vont
disparaître bah oui parce que autant
voter Macron
et moi j'ai beaucoup de républicains de
mer républicains d'adhérents républicain
qui adhèrent à debout la France j'ai
jamais eu autant d'adhésions le jour où
il y a eu cette image donc si vous avez
des adhésions depuis que les
républicains ont dit qu'ils allaient
terrible mais cette image à combien moi
j'en sais rien ce que je vois bien vous
savez c'est pas énorme mais c'est pas
les questions c'est que ces symbolique
c'est à dire que le jour enfin les
Français comment peut-on aller aux
élections législatives et être dans
l'opposition et se dire dans
l'opposition et cette réforme absurde se
précipiter pour la voter
moi c'est ta compréhensible pour moi
m'écouter les la vie des partis
politiques à des mystères je croyais
qu'Eric Ciotti avait été élu pour
s'opposer et son premier geste
malheureusement c'est de c'est de servir
la soupe à un gouvernement qui
complètement fou exception faite
justement de cette réforme des retraites
qu'est-ce qui est aujourd'hui vous
distingue direction dans le paysage
politique ben c'est plutôt à lui de voir
ce qu'il va faire Éric ce titre dit des
choses souvent justes sur les sécurités
sur l'immigration mais vous savez c'est
pas le problème de dire c'est de faire
avec lui depuis qu'il a pris la tête des
républicains
où les républicains votent cette réforme
surréaliste enfin c'est incompréhensible
pour moi incompréhensible mais je vais
vous dire l'opinion
à très bien compris donc maintenant
c'est leur chemin moi c'est pas moi je
suis pas républicain j'ai quitté ce
parti il y a 15 ans sur l'Europe
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant ce qui se
passe parce que cette réforme elle a
deux objectifs trois objectifs
premier objectif d'Emmanuel Macron c'est
pas les retraites c'est très bien que il
y en a pas besoin maintenant cette
réforme premier objectif c'est de piéger
les républicains ils sont tombés dans le
piège voilà tout de suite deuxième
objectif c'est de plaire à Madame
vanderleyen à l'Union européenne et
troisième objectif c'est de servir la
soupe à Blackrock au fond
d'investissement américain parce qu'à
partir du moment où vous créez
l'angoisse j'ai tous les Français alors
répété toute la journée que le système
n'est pas financé alors qu'il l'est au
lieu de créer de l'emploi parce qu'il
faut s'occuper des retraites mais par
les recettes relocaliser avoir une
politique nataliste politique familiale
moi je suis pas il faut avoir un plan de
reconstitution les réserves des
retraites bref il y a des choses à faire
pour les retraites l'emploi des seniors
il s'agit pas de dire il y a rien à
faire mais on a le temps donc moi je
crois qu'il faut positiver les choses il
faut préparer notre pays il faut le
muscler finalement c'est une bonne
nouvelle que la droite joue le jeu du
gouvernement pour vous pour vous de vous
la France et dans le cas de cette
recomposition cette recomposition là
elle est en marche et puis dire c'est le
cas de le dire écoutez
je me réjouis pas de ça je vais vous
dire parce que je trouve ça détestable
pour d'abord les électeurs ont été
trompés républicains ils ont été trompés
ils ont cru voter pour des députés
d'opposition ils vont voter pour des
députés de la majorité c'est terrible et
puis moi ça me fait de la peine que des
personnalités que j'estime ce fourvoyent
avec un homme qui détruit la France et
c'est leur choix quelques questions
politiques et d'actualité pour terminer
d'abord Adrien katmans puisque il va
siéger pendant quatre mois à vos côtés
du coup puisqu'il est chez les non
inscrits c'est pas un groupe
inscrits comme vous est-ce qu'il a eu
raison de revenir à l'Assemblée après
avoir été condamné pour violon
moi je je suis pas juge il a été
condamné par la justice après les
Français jugeront voilà mais moi je fais
pas de problème mais bien sûr ça pose un
problème énorme de crédibilité
d'exemplarité
autre question alors cette fois c'est
des questions qui concernent les hausses
des prix puisque c'est évidemment un
sujet de préoccupation pour les Français
le gouvernement dit vouloir mettre en
place un panier anti-inflation la
ministre l'hiver Grégoire va demander à
la grande distribution de vendre une
vingtaine d'articles de première
nécessité du quotidien a pris quasi
coûtant parce que il faut se souvenir le
budget des consommateurs vous soutenez
cette demande madame Grégoire a beaucoup
d'imagination la première chose que
Madame Grégoire devrait faire mais c'est
pas elle qui décide c'est de revenir au
prix national de l'électricité comme la
Belgique comme la Belgique comme le
l'Espagne et le Portugal ce qui
éviterait ces usines à gaz d'ailleurs
très dispendieuses mais enfin l'État se
rattrape aussi
de grâce l'urgence absolue pour le
pouvoir d'achat c'est revenir un prix
national
arrêter
le raquette des sociétés privées
d'électricité et qui font leurs courses
et de produits d'hygiène est-ce que vous
soutenez cette demande mais il y a une
mesure beaucoup plus efficace
que cette espèce de bowling ou là c'est
la TVA 0 % que j'ai proposé pendant la
présidentielle sur 20 articles j'ai même
été avec un caddie montrer ce que ça
faisait comme réduction voilà donc si
Madame Grégoire était vous savez
pourquoi c'est à la charge de l'État là
c'est à la charge des distributs là ça
veut dire ça marchera pas tout ça c'est
du cinéma c'est la communication les
Français n'en peuvent pas vous les
distributeurs
c'est du gadget c'est du gadget en fait
nous sommes dans un avec un gouvernement
qui passe sa vie à communiquer et moi je
vais vous dire ce qui m'inquiète vous
disiez est-ce que c'est bien pour vous
et tout ce que je trouve désastreux
aujourd'hui c'est que les Français n'ont
plus confiance dans la parole politique
du tout parce que ce n'est que gadget
mot d'ordre il y a besoin de sérieux
donc moi j'ai fait une proposition on la
connaît
elle est chiffrable j'ai même publié un
bouquin où va le pognon je dégage 50
milliards d'économies parce que ce qui
est paradoxal dans ce qui se passe c'est
quand même temps on gaspille l'argent
public
il y a 5 millions de fausses cartes
vitales il y a eu des rapports
sénatoriaux vous savez bien qu'est-ce
qu'on fait pourquoi donc vous savez les
Français comprennent pas que l'État
laisse gaspiller partir l'argent des
Français et de l'autre côté n'assure pas
le le
l'essentiel voilà moi il y a de l'argent
à trouver il faut faire des économies
à partir de 9h les Français vont pouvoir
se connecter sur le site des impôts pour
les Français les plus modestes ça
concerne 10 millions de travailleurs
français pour bénéficier d'une carburant
de 100 euros d'ailleurs deux personnes
ont même coupe peuvent en bénéficier
c'est une cible pour remplacer les la
ristourne à la pompe c'est une bonne
démarche ou pas c'est mieux que rien
mais moi je n'aime pas du tout ce
système d'échec permanent je n'aime pas
cette bureaucratie ces usines à gaz
inventées dans tous les sens on s'y perd
d'ailleurs les fonctionnaires ça même
plus comment ça fonctionne c'est un coût
considérable moi je crois au système des
prix je crois qu'il faut agir en amont
donc c'est mieux que rien mais vous
savez ce gouvernement on le voit sur
l'électricité il laisse un prix
exorbitant et puis après il fait des
cadeaux alors comme ça il a le beau rôle
mais les Français sont pas dupe et en
plus ça marche pas donc c'est ça crée
beaucoup de confusion moi je pense qu'il
faut revenir un système des prix le plus
simple possible voilà je préférais une
baisse de la taxe sur l'essence comme on
avait fait c'était beaucoup plus simple
merci Nicolas Dupont-Aignan merci
Fabrice
invité politique c'est la